so
foreign
i also
this is
babies
oh
thank you
just
please
[Music]
my
so
oh
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
uh
[Music]
from
[Music]
mr president
mr provost madam secretary
deans college heads college deans
colleagues friends families
and most of all
members of the class of 2022 welcome to
this day and congratulations
[Applause]
i now call on the university chaplain
you got this
with deep gratitude to the quinnipiac
people for this land on which we stand
my beloved yale family i invite you to
join me in the spirit of prayer
almighty and loving god
you are the one who gives us this day
and all our days
in the majesty of this life moment we
your beloved children of different
colors creeds generations stories and
tongues are gathered in this place as
one human family united in jubilant
celebration
we are filled with gratitude for our
families friends teachers and guides
their arms have sheltered us
their shoulders have boosted us
and today their hearts soar for us
eternal god it is you who calls us to
our full humanity
as we celebrate our accomplishments we
are humbled and overwhelmed by what lies
ahead
we live in a world fraught with
heartache and our time at yale has been
a blend of loss
uncertainty discovery and reconnection
steady us
so that we may find ways to caress the
beauty of your creation
and let our souls know true delight
as we awaken to the wonder and mystery
of our own unfolding lives
through the unity of mind and spirit
hold us ever close as we seek to leven
your world wisely in the steadfast
pursuit of your light
and your truth
for this we say amen
now you may be seated
that which pervades earth sky and heaven
which is worthy of worship that has no
beginning
that which is the light of wisdom and
truth
let us meditate on the radiance of that
divinity
may that brilliance help inspire and
illuminate our minds
that one which represents water
light and is the quintessence in all
things
may that almighty spirit pervading the
earth
atmosphere and heaven bless us with
enlightenment
send forth your light and your truth
they will lead me
they will bring me to your holy mountain
to your dwelling place that i may come
to the altar of god
god my delight my joy let me praise you
with the harp
o god
my god
you are the light of the world
a city built on a hill cannot be hid
no one after lighting a lamp puts it
under the bushel basket
but on the lampstand
and it gives light to all in the house
in the same way
let your light shine before others
so that they may see your good works
and give glory to your god in
[Applause]
[Music]
heaven god is the light of the heavens
and earth
the likeness of his light is that of a
niche
in which there is a lamp
the lamp is in a glass
the glass is
as it were a brilliant star
lit from a blessed tree
an olive tree
neither of the east
nor of the west
whose oil seems to glow
even though no fire has touched it
light upon light
god guides whom he wills to his light
god makes parables for humanity
and god has knowledge of everything
uh
oh
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
on this occasion
it is customary for the president to
deliver a baccalaureate address and for
the dean of yale college to offer
readings
today we celebrate your journey through
yale not the end of your time here but
instead the beginning the commencement
ahead
the love of learning that you cultivated
here will light your past forward for a
lifetime
that love of learning can lead you in
any direction you want
to service to scholarship
to leadership
it might also lead you to happiness
and in fact you may have discovered that
learning is itself a form of happiness
one of the happiest people who helped
you here is known to many of you
david swenson yale's chief investment
officer who died last year
was deeply involved in supporting the
university's mission
and he was a devoted mentor to students
here is what he would often say about
you when he talked about supporting
yale's mission
i love the idea that undergraduates have
this opportunity to study whatever they
want
students will say to me
what do i need to take to be attractive
to an investment bank
i say don't do that
take great classes that you like
who are the teachers who changed how you
think about the world and yourself
what were your happiest activities and
who were the people who shared them with
you
i hope that you know exactly who these
people are
and that you have thanked them
in and out of the classroom with these
teachers mentors and friends
think about all the ways you have
practiced being happy every day
university of california professor sonja
liubermerski
a former student of the late psychology
professor susan nolan hoksima
studies positive psychology and
happiness
here she is as though speaking to you
now
the face of happiness may be someone who
is intensely curious and enthusiastic
about learning
it may be someone who is engrossed in
plans for his next five years
it may be someone who can distinguish
between the things that matter and the
things that don't
it may be someone who looks forward each
night to reading to her child
in other words we all have the potential
to be happy
each in our own way
what these activities have in common is
that they help you be focused in the
moment
something known as flow
let me quote yale's own happiness
scholar and teacher professor lori
santos
if i may
even as she's sitting up here on stage
as a head of college
sorry
challenging activities give us what
positive psychologists call flow
the state where we're feeling really
present
and involved
and it's kind of hard but doable
it's not so easy that it's boring
and research suggests that flow states
feel really good
author sean aker
who also happens to be a former
collaborator of president salovey also
studies happiness and offers similar
advice
happiness is a mindset for your journey
not the result of your destination
waiting to be happy limits our brain's
potential for success
whereas cultivating positive brains
makes us more motivated efficient
resilient
creative and productive
which drives performance upward
the way we define happiness is the joy
you feel striving toward your potential
the commencement ahead
your life of realizing your talents and
values you in fact have already begun
guided by your love of learning
my final reading comes from john milton
who famously describes some young people
you might recognize
and who like you
found themselves taking their first
steps into a new world
beyond the one they knew and loved
as you take your own first steps i offer
him to you now from his paradise lost
some natural tears they dropped but
wiped them soon
the world was all before them where to
choose
their place of rest and providence their
guide
they hand in hand with wandering steps
and slow
through eden took their solitary way
congratulations yale college class of
2022.
[Applause]
oh
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
leo
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
holy boy
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
wow
graduates of the class
of 2022
family members friends and colleagues
before i get started
i want to mention that this is the last
baccalaureate
at least in his present role
for your dean
marvin chun
before he returns to the faculty
and i'm wondering if we could all show
him just a little bit of gratitude for
his service these last five years
he's not going far away
so
it is a
special pleasure to be here with you
today a day made doubly meaningful by
our ability to celebrate our graduates
in person
and i'm delighted to welcome you to
yale's first on-campus baccalaureate
ceremony
since the start of the coven 19 pandemic
and after a three-year hiatus there is a
wonderful yale tradition
that i would like to reinstitute
may i ask all the families and friends
here today
to rise and recognize the outstanding
and graduating members of the class of
2022
[Applause]
thank you and now may i ask the class of
2022
to consider all those who have supported
your arrival at this milestone
and to please rise and recognize them
[Music]
thank you
our excitement today
is tempered by global
we can see the perils of conflict and
crisis around the world
and yet
as i look out onto this courtyard
i can also see the promise
of those well prepared
to better our collective future
old campuses filled anew
with the boundless potential of
graduates
who offer cause
for hope
throughout the country on this weekend
those weekends surrounding it
presidents of colleges and universities
are inspiring their graduating seniors
by telling them
that they have received the
very best education possible
and that as educated adults
they are now ready to go out and make
the world a better place
this is of course true in many respects
and i've certainly spoken on other
commencement weekends of the importance
of improving the world for this and
future generations
but i would like you
graduating seniors from yale college
to depart from this place
with a somewhat different mindset
i'm going to urge you to recognize
that your excellent education
allows you to listen to others carefully
consider what they have to say
and sometimes
come to a new point of view i'm
suggesting today a day filled with the
pride of accomplishment
to recognize
at the same time
the value
of intellectual humility
today i wish to focus on the courage to
acknowledge all we do not know
to admit when we are wrong
and to change our minds
60 years ago president john f kennedy
spoke to a capacity audience seated
right where you are now
he saw a similar state of unrest as the
specter of war
loomed
and i suspect he gained a similar sense
of optimism atop this platform
from members of the class
of 1962.
president kennedy's
commencement address at yale
was sweeping in its rhetoric and its
scope
and more than a half a century later
there is still much for us to heed from
his message
including the abiding but now especially
relevant value
of seeking new perspectives
too often president kennedy told the
graduates in a rousing appeal for
intellectual humility
too often
we subject all facts
to a pre-fabricated set
of interpretations
too often he continued we enjoy the
comfort of opinion
without the discomfort
of thought
history teaches us the grave hazard of
certitude and the hubris from which it
germinates
now
when i was a graduate student here
professor irving janus a social
psychologist
was one of my teachers
he formulated the concept of group think
and linked the suppression of dissent to
a series of foreign policy debacles
such as the escalation of the vietnam
war
and the bay of pigs
invasion the bay of pigs invasion a
decision by kennedy to have the cia lead
a group of armed cuban exiles in a
failed attempt to overthrow fidel castro
was described by kennedy aide arthur
schlesinger
as rooted in a curious atmosphere of
assumed consensus in which no one spoke
against it
and as president kennedy himself
disclosed to time magazine
there were 50 or so of us
presumably the most experienced and
smartest people we could get
to plan
such an operation
most of us thought it would work
i wasn't aware of any great opposition
yet when we saw the wide range of
failures kennedy continued we asked
ourselves why had it not been apparent
to somebody from the start
i guess you get walled off from reality
when you want something to succeed too
much
the invasion was an embarrassment to the
united states and in those cold war days
it pushed cuba closer to the soviet
union
in the many years since president
kennedy spoke at yale
silos in which unchecked opinion
confined refuge
have become both ubiquitous and more
easily accessed
they act as echo chambers that reaffirm
beliefs
in real time
within these silos speculation travels
great distances
without scrutiny
and the spirit of discord between these
silos discourages the honest exchange of
ideas
across them
in short
clinging to our circles of consensus has
grown more comforting
and questioning them
more difficult
i encourage you to reject that comfort
because a willingness to explore new
ideas is what makes all the difference
you know this perfectly well i realize
the diversity of academic experiences
available
here at yale in short
that you were not limited to learning
from
those who already shared your outlook
indeed president kennedy chose to speak
of such matters at yale
because of the self-evident truth that a
great university
is always enlisted
against the spread of illusion
and on the side
of reality
another social psychologist mark leary
who recently retired from the faculty of
duke university
closely examined the intellectual
humility
i seek to nurture in higher education
generally
and in you today
his review of this attribute a
recognition that one's beliefs and
opinions might be
incorrect reveals that it is associated
with gratitude
altruism empathy
and more satisfying relationships
intellectually humble people are more
likely to be forgiven by others
for their mistakes
as extremism polarization and gridlock
plague our politics
at a time when pressing challenges call
on us to harness our shared humanity
professor leary details equally
substantial advantages of intellectual
humility for society
including lower acrimony that is based
on differences in beliefs and ideology
and greater negotiation
and compromise
now when we first met four years ago in
wolsey hall
i described a series of obligations that
would accompany your yale
education
including the responsibility to be
constantly curious and to listen
carefully to others
at that 2018 opening assembly i
encourage members of this class to
remember that you have come to yell
because you don't know everything
not yet
now
even as you prepare to depart yale four
years later i will again declare that
your acquisition of knowledge is
unfinished
you will leave yell despite
not knowing everything
the transformative power of liberal
education lies not in a promise to teach
you everything
but in the preparedness to meet
presumptions
including those we harbor
ourselves
with a healthy measure
of doubt
it lies not in the ability to answer
but in the audacity
to question
as graduates it behooves you to carry
forth the inquisitive attitude you have
forged here at yale
into the world
to carry forth your insistence on
pushing opinions including your own
beyond the confines of comfort
your resolve to strengthen your
reasoning through personal investigation
and civil discourse
in thinking of these trademarks of the
academic enterprise i'm reminded of a
dictum from rabbi moses ben myman the
great
medieval philosopher known as maimonides
in his introduction to parque a vote the
ethics of our fathers maimonides urges
readers
to accept the truth
from whoever speaks it
indeed wisdom is rooted in this
willingness this responsibility to
entertain ideas brought to you by others
to listen carefully
to think critically
to challenge your views and then to
change them when the discovery of truth
demands it
as justice sonia sotomayor said recently
it is i fear
too easy for people to fail to listen
when what they're hearing is different
than what they think
as we know
engaging with those who hold profoundly
different perspectives threatens not to
betray our beliefs
but to broaden them listening to that
with which we may disagree is an act not
of conciliation
but of fidelity to truth
and admitting what we got wrong
is no sign of failure but a necessary
step
toward knowledge
the mark of a great education consists
not only of the new frontiers of
knowledge we reach
but of the existing viewpoints
we reconsider
not necessarily of the understanding we
gain
but of the assumptions
we shed
for only when we subject the
prefabricated set of interpretations
president kennedy spoke of here at yale
to scrutiny
can we elevate our limitations
into points of strength
indeed humility
that willingness to say we are wrong
enables us to scale otherwise
unattainable heights
in the lifelong pursuit
of knowledge
as yell graduates you are allegiant to
truth
you know that breakthroughs are
byproducts of the questions you raise
the conventions you dispute
the fallacies
you uncover
but also the mistakes
you own
you know that the new ideas and
solutions i spoke of when we first
assembled as a class four years ago
ideas and solutions to fight disease
alleviate suffering
and find justice
are made better
when they endure the rigors
of critical inquiry
perhaps now more than ever
the world into which you will soon enter
needs you to search for these solutions
it needs your expertise
but it also needs your example as a
graduate of this inspiring learning
environment
it needs you to continue probing the
preconceptions held by others and with
equal vigor those you hold yourself
it needs your answers and your questions
it needs your scholarship and your
skepticism it needs your intellectual
prowess
and it needs
your intellectual
humility
it needs
you
class of 2022.
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
please
[Music]
is
[Music]
may god bless you and keep you
may the eternal show you favor and be
gracious to you
may the holy one cause light to shine
upon you and grant you peace and let us
say amen
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
you